in my early days as a graduate student I
went on a snorkeling trip off the coast
of the Bahamas I'd actually never swum
in the ocean before so it was a bit
terrifying when I remember the most is
that as I put my head in the water and I
was trying really hard to breathe
through the snorkel this huge group of
striped yellow and black fish came
straight at me and I just froze
and then as if it had suddenly changed
its mind came towards me and then
swerved to the right and went right
around me it was absolutely mesmerizing
maybe many of you have had this
experience of course there's the color
and the beauty of it but there was also
just the sheer oneness of it as if it
wasn't hundreds of fish but a single
entity with a single collective mind
that was making decisions when I look
back I think that experience really
ended up determining what I've worked on
for most of my career I'm a computer
scientist and the field that I work in
is artificial intelligence and a key
theme in AI is being able to understand
intelligence by creating our own
computational systems that display
intelligence the way we see it in nature
now most popular views of AI of course
come from science fiction in the movies
and I'm personally a big star Wars fan
but that tends to be a very human
centric view of intelligence when you
think of a fish school or when I think
of a flock of starlings that feels like
a really different kind of intelligence
for starters any one fish is just so
tiny compared to the sheer size of the
collective so it seems that any one
individual would have a really limited
myopic view of what's going on and
intelligence isn't really about the
individual but somehow property of the
group itself secondly and the thing that
I
still find most remarkable is that we
know that there are no leaders
supervising this fish school instead
this incredible collective mind behavior
is emerging purely from the interactions
of one fish and another somehow there
are these interactions or rules of
engagement between neighboring fish that
make it all work out so the question for
AI then becomes what are those rules of
engagement that lead to this kind of
intelligence and of course can we create
our own and that's the primary thing
that I work on with my team in my lab we
work on it through theory looking at
abstract rules systems and thinking
about the mathematics behind it we also
do it through biology working closely
with experimentalist
but mostly we do it through robotics
where we try to create our own
collective systems that can do the kinds
of things that we see in nature or at
least try to one of our first robotic
quests along this line was to create our
very own colony of a thousand robots
so very simple robots but that could be
programmed to exhibit collective
intelligence and that's what we were
able to do so this is what a single
robot looks like it's quite small about
the size of a quarter and you can
program how it moves but it can also
wirelessly communicate with other robots
and it can measure distances from them
and so now we can start to program
exactly an interaction a rule of
engagement between neighbors and once we
have this system we can start to program
many different kinds of rules of
engagement that you would see in nature
so for example spontaneous
synchronization how audiences are
clapping and suddenly they start all
clapping together fireflies flashing
together we can program rules for
pattern formation how cells in a tissue
determine what role they're going to
take on and set the patterns of our
bodies we can program rules for
migration and in this way we're really
learning from nature's rules but we can
also take it a step further we can
actually take these rules that we
learn from nature and combine them and
create entirely new collective behaviors
of our very own so for example imagine
that you have two different kinds of
rules so your first rule is a motion
rule where a moving robot can move
around other stationary robots and your
second rule is a pattern rule where a
robot takes on a color based on its two
nearest neighbors so if I start with a
blob of robots and a little pattern seed
it turns out that these two rules are
sufficient for the group to be able to
self-assemble a simple line pattern and
if I have more complicated pattern rules
and I design error correction rules we
can actually create really really
complicated self assemblies and here's
what that looks like so here you're
gonna see a thousand robots there are
working together to self assemble the
letter K the K is on its side and the
important thing is that no one is in
charge so any single robot is only
talking to a small number of robots
nearby it and it's using its motion rule
to move around the half-filled structure
just looking for a place to fit in based
on its pattern rules and even though no
robot is doing anything perfectly the
rules are such that we can get the
collective to do its goal robustly
together and the illusion becomes almost
so perfect you know you just start to
not even notice that they're individual
robots at all and it becomes a single
entity kind of like the school of fish
so these are robots and rules in two
dimensions but we can also think about
robots and rules in three dimensions so
what if we could create robots that
could build together and here we can
take inspiration from social insects so
if you think about mound building
termites or you think about army ants
they create incredible complex nest
structures out of mud and even out of
their own bodies and like the system I
showed you before these insects actually
also have pattern rules that help them
determine what to build but the pattern
can be made out of other insects or it
could be made out of mud and we can use
that same
to create rules for robots so here
you're gonna see some simulated robots
so the simulated robot has a motion rule
which is how it traverses through the
structure looking for a place to fit in
and it has pattern rules where it looks
at groups of blocks to decide whether to
place a block and with the right motion
rules and the right pattern rules we can
actually get the robots to build
whatever we want and of course everybody
wants their own Tower so once we have
these rules we can start to create the
robot bodies that go with these rules so
here you see a robot that can climb over
blocks but it can also lift and move
these blocks and it can start to edit
the very structure that it's on but with
these rules this is really only one kind
of robot body that you could imagine you
could imagine many different kinds of
robot bodies so if you think about
robots that maybe could move sandbags
and could help build levees or we could
think of robots that build out of soft
materials and worked together to shore
up a collapsed building so just the same
kind of rules in different kinds of
bodies or if like my group you are
completely obsessed with army ants then
maybe one day we can make robots that
can climb over literally anything
including other members of their tribe
and cells assemble things out of their
own bodies once you understand the rules
just many different kinds of robot
visions become possible and coming back
to the snorkeling trip we actually
understand a great deal about the rules
that fish schools use so if we can
invent the bodies to go with that then
maybe there is a future where I and my
group will get to snorkel with a fish
school of our own creation each of these
systems that I showed you brings us
closer to having the mathematical and
the conceptual tools to create our own
versions of collective power and this
can enable many different kinds of
future
applications whether you think about
robots that build flood barriers or you
think about robotic bee colonies that
could pollinate crops or underwater
schools of robots that monitor coral
reefs or if we reach for the stars and
we think about programming
constellations of satellites in each of
these systems being able to understand
how to design the rules of engagement
and being able to create good collective
behavior becomes a key to realizing
these visions so so far I've talked
about rules for insects and for fish and
for robots but what about the rules that
apply to our own human collective and
the last thought that I'd like to leave
you with is that science is of course
itself an incredible manifestation of
collective intelligence but unlike the
beautiful fish schools that I study I
feel we still have a much longer
evolutionary path to walk so in addition
to working on improving the science of
robot collectives I also work on
creating robots and thinking about rules
that will improve our own scientific
collective there's the saying that I
love who does science determines what
science gets done imagine a society
where we had rules of engagement where
every child grew up believing that they
could stand here and be a technologist
of the future or where every adult
believed that they had the ability not
just to understand but to change how
science and technology impacts their
everyday lives what would that society
look like I believe that we can do that
I believe that we can choose our rules
and we can engineer not just robots but
we can engineer our own human collective
and if we do and when we do it will be
beautiful thank you
[Applause]
[Music]